Speaker 1: Let's go to let's go to Ricky from
Charlotte. Ricky, you can unmute yourself and then
I'll be able to hear you and then we'll be able to
talk and it'll be great. Ricky You are self muted,
but you can unmute and then you will be all good.
Speaker 3: Hey, do you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Okay. Awesome. I wanted
to ask you. I'm trying to sort of digest the
results from the election and get an idea of
a lot of the meanings of the results. And
one of the things I was thinking about was.
The the Republicans underperformance. What
is. What do you think this means about
a lot of the right's efforts and investments going
all in on cultural wars and and especially like
a lot of their a lot of the investments they
made an alternative media seemed like outlets
like the Daily Wire Turning Points USA and and
then just you know, a plethora of different like
online streamers and people like Tim Paul
and like all these things are doing like
the disaffected liberal dance and and things like
that. And seeing that, it, it seems to me like I'm
just surprised that none of it has really shown
up electorally. I mean, is is that surprising?
Speaker 1: I don't think it's
surprising. And here's why.
Based on what we saw online, it wouldn't have
been crazy to expect Bernie Sanders to win the
2020 Democratic primary. If you looked online, you
would have thought. Tulsi Gabbard certainly must
have more than 2% support and Bernie's probably
going to run away with this thing. And of course,
that wasn't the case because so much of what
voters do doesn't involve posting to Twitter
and Reddit or whatever the case. So sometimes we
like misunderstand the size of a movement based
on looking at social media. Similarly, even
though, for example, in the lead up to 2022,
much of what we heard from Trump and Kerry
League and others was about they stole 20,
20 and I really won and all this different stuff.
A lot of Republican voters are not interested in
that. And and to some degree, they rejected it.
Right. They rejected J. Ahmadu, Suki and John
Gibbs and Kerry Lake and Tudor DICKERSON and
so on and so forth. Now, I think the risk is
some people look at one election and they take
some huge overarching conclusion from it, and
we really shouldn't do that. Each election gives
us a little bit of information about a couple of
things. So like, it's not that the Stop the steal
stuff isn't real within the Republican electorate,
it's just not quite as popular as it might seem
from following Trump. And so it didn't go that
well for Republicans. And so the important
thing I think for Democrats to do is to try
to get a better grasp on what isn't working
for Republicans. And for example, it was a
good strategy for Democrats to play up the the
big lie stuff in 2022 because they correctly
assessed a lot of Republicans aren't going for
it. I don't know that there has to be some grand
takeaway, but it's a lot of little takeaways.
Speaker 3: Yeah. No, I definitely agree with
a lot of the little takeaways and the themes, you
know, in the in the results. But the, I guess the
thing that I, I'm just like really interested
in is. It seems to me like on a national level,
like the Republican politicians have really like
adopted a lot of online rhetoric and language and
you see like a lot of proximity with what, you
know, this this new movement of like young right
wing conservatives like Ben SHAPIRO on The Daily
Wire and Charlie Kirk and all of them. And, you
know, and they have these things like they have
CPAC in the Charlie Group, like has Charlie Kirk's
group has like multiple events and stuff per year.
And I'm like, is that is that just like is it just
they are investing in all that because they're
trying to push back against the fact that there's
this rising young voters that are left wing.
Speaker 1: And to some degree, yeah,
I think they see the demographics. They know
that 18 to 29 year olds are voting pretty
left. And and unfortunately, they are smart to
do what they're doing. They are pouring money
into trying to grab up those young voters.
And so my concern is, even though 18 to 29
year olds and soon to be 18 year olds are a
huge opportunity for the Democratic Party,
the Democratic Party doesn't seem as
committed to pouring the money in to
independent media shows and events and this
type of thing. The right is smart to do it,
and the left needs to get on the ball.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So you think it could eventually
start showing some electoral effect?
Speaker 1: It could. It could.
Speaker 3: Okay. Yeah, well, I hope that
they catch up on this because, you know,
I mean, I am glad to see that they weren't
able to effectively making or training the
kids. Is this number one issue? I don't think
anybody really voted on that and stuff, but
they're clearly trying a lot with this cultural.
Speaker 1: They absolutely are. Absolutely are.
We got to be ready. Ricky, thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There is. Ricki,